The jogan Experience did you see that
new movie the uh I haven't seen it yet
what is it called the new Netflix movie
it's an apocalyptic oh it sucks of the
World movie oh I didn't like it yeah I
did see it no I did not like it how dare
you what's it called Leave the World
Behind Leave the World Behind you
thought it sucked I didn't like it what
did you not like about it I just thought
it I don't know it just didn't I loved
it you loved it loved it yeah I didn't
like it yeah the only thing I didn't
love is the animals showing up in their
backyard I'm like this doesn't that
seemed a little over the top it seemed a
little over the top if I think what I
didn't like about it it seemed a little
over the top I like the theme of it I
liked how they kind of turned on each
other a little bit Yeah but not too much
not too much but it's coming yeah yeah
yeah you think they're preparing us yeah
well for sure they set up a fair for
sure Ethan's weak and the other dude is
strong and you know that's going to work
out well you know I mean there's not
enough people yeah Julia Roberts still
looks great yeah yeah you know the the
the thing that threw me off in that
movie was the fake animals the CGI
animals like that does you like you just
took me away you've developed this
intense psychological Thriller you don't
need to have this weird animal mystery
thing in the middle go anywhere exactly
well there's no logic behind it there's
no reason why the animals would all just
show up in your backyard like that and
they never explained it or nothing ever
happened unless you live in Texas
they're are everywhere but they're
everywhere every day yeah this this this
movie was great and not so great in the
in the same time like that part was not
so great because it didn't make any
sense but the rest of it did make sense
that people do go sideways you know yeah
I thought that um who was um who played
the guy that oh Kevin Bacon the crazy
guy underrated actor he's so good such a
good actor very good I would have liked
to have seen him more yeah that's the
thing why you have one scene this
fascinating guy who's already prepared I
agree with you it was it seemed like
that whole in the house stuff was like a
little we got it like we kind of got
that part we yeah and also the tension
didn't go anywhere they up being friends
you know like the girl and Julia Roberts
like they they hate each other they
bitching each other then they're hugging
each other at one point in time what are
we doing what why did you make them
[__] CUNY to each other yeah you know
that was just that yeah I didn't love I
just didn't think it was it could have
been better why did he not have his
wallet on him like what is all about
this drives there with oh it must have
left it in my jacket and it looks fake
you're setting me up there's real drama
the world is over there's real drama why
do you got this weird interpersonal
drama
there he is he was good in it yeah and
you know what's really fascinating there
was this one weird moment where uh the
daughter and uh what is the gentleman's
name the guy same guy that's playing
blade right Mar sure I'm not how do you
say his name he's awesome though he was
great it he's awesome he was great it
just like when the daughter said to him
you can't trust white people everybody
got so mad everybody get so mad isn't
this a movie where two black people are
in a house with white people at the end
of the world you don't think that's a
reasonable thing to say no it's also
part of the black psyche it's they're
always thinking that they're always
thinking like can I trust this guy yeah
well why wouldn't you say that you're a
young girl that's on brand you're a
young girl with tattoos and nose rings
and you say don't trust white people duh
yeah duh why would people be upset at
that yeah look Obama made this movie and
this is what this is the agenda no
that's not watch the movie that's not
what it's about or hang out with black
people there's always a little something
where there they always have it in their
head a little bit oh they always have a
story you're like what did he say to you
they went through some trauma yeah
that's what he said to me and you're
like
whoa that one-on-one racism when no
one's around is got to be the scariest
[__] yeah that's got to be the scariest
[__] yeah you can't just wash away that
trauma it happened yeah it's also it's a
movie it's a movie about people that are
experiencing heavy levels of anxiety
where the world is over yeah there's war
going on no one knows what happen planes
are falling from the sky this girl's
mom's dead probably spoiler alert well
everyone's like overreacting now to the
uh yeah how how that's been politicized
right like the race stuff and the Dei so
if they see any glimpse of that they
just attach they get mad even if it's
just a reasonable part of a story I mean
you got to give people room in fiction
to make realistic human beings if you
don't think a realistic 20-some year old
girl who's with her dad with her in a
guest bedroom of their own [__] house
because these other people air being
beated but the end of the world is here
you don't think you'd have some [__]
shitty things to say especially if no
one's around especially if the woman who
Julie Roberts is acting like shitty yeah
at the begin yeah doesn't trust you yeah
everything everyone's so charged now on
the culture
War